the Joe Rogan experience and you start
thinking about all the possibilities
what could happen and then the this
pandemic happens and then you know yeah
yes I still live in the same place where
I did the show you know it's like I
started seeing you know I'm here in Los
Angeles you saw him - all of a sudden
you seen Black Hawk helicopters going by
about that time you see an Apache
helicopters going by you're seeing the
Ospreys you see the Ospreys going by
every day and the first week of this and
you're thinking what's going on man do
you watch The Walking Dead you know I I
haven't watched it let me tell you I
know it's crazy Walking Dead the first
two seasons hear about it now the first
few seasons were awesome but maybe even
better is the first season of the LA
version of The Walking Dead what's that
one called the first the first couple
episodes of that is spectacular yeah
it's the first season is pretty good but
it said they did it very differently
than the other Walking Dead but you know
it just like where it people it takes a
while for people to realize what the
[ __ ] is happening mm-hmm it sort of felt
like because that time the beginning in
the beginning oh yeah man in the
beginning it felt touch-and-go when
everybody was horndog with - toilet
paper and we're fighting yo and everyone
wants a gun the gun lines were giant
right mm the lines outside the gun
stores were creepy yeah yeah were you in
one of those lines
I'm not waiting in line I have a theory
about the toilet paper
maybe it's obvious but but I don't know
maybe it's not obvious I don't know
so toilet papers big yes
so because it's big takes up a lot of
shelf space because it takes up a lot
everyone's talked about this already but
maybe takes up a lot of shelf space so
all of a sudden everybody went to the
grocery store at the same time and
there's probably far less toilet paper
than at the grocery store then it would
appear just because it takes an entire
aisle because it's big
so everybody what bought one piece of
packaged of toilet paper on the first
day it was instantly all gone it's
instantly an entire empty aisle which is
dramatic looking hmm and it was the
first sign of shelves being cleared and
it was the toilet paper was gone
and everyone went on their [ __ ]
phones there's putting a running toilet
paper
and all of a sudden that compounded it
exponentially and now everyone's going
for the toilet paper and they don't need
to be going for the toilet paper and we
had the great toilet paper shortage of
2020 this is the type of investigative
reporting you do when you're alone that
makes a hundred percent sense because
it's big
we wouldn't grabbed a can of corn
everyone grabs can of beans but it
didn't create an entire empty aisle that
then got people thinking talking and and
and tweeting and typing and
instagramming it's also something dumb
people think about a lot of [ __ ]
yeah yeah it's you don't want to not be
able to wipe your ass yeah but all the
things you need like do you understand
what it's like when [ __ ] goes down get a
rag and a bucket of water okay right
wash your ass with a washcloth right cuz
[ __ ] is going down yeah all right that's
the last thing you need to worry about
is toilet paper you need to worry about
consuming food and staying alive yeah
some people don't think it's ever gonna
get to that and those are the ones that
stock up on toilet paper yeah the ones
you buy like rice and beans and stuff
like that those are the people that are
planning their legitimately planning
ahead you want to stay alive mm-hmm they
say yes you know that's right
use a Heinz corn and rice as a that's
what I Ren was a subsys enough enough
vitamins and everything you need so sure
you don't get enough protein that way
but you get some from being oh really
yes it's not as available sometimes
bioavailable as it is in other foods
yeah yeah so he gets some protein we
just gotta eat a lot yeah it's not as
complete as some forms of protein
[Applause]